a lot of people out there were surprised
when Kanye West announced that he was
running for president oh but wait wait
until you hear what he had to say in his
first interview about his candidacy
I just want to take a picture right now
Kanye is running for president under a
new banner the birthday party why
because when we win it's everybody's
birthday now let's go other revelations
from Kanye's for our phone interview
with Forbes magazine he envisions a
White House organized like Black
Panthers fictional country of Wakanda so
who are the rappers advisers for
starters white Kim did you know that he
was gonna announce his candidacy or
possible I did not is he serious no way
he's serious he is I I believe he is
serious if he puts his mind to something
he'll do his best
also on Kanye's committee Elon Musk who
says he will head up the country's space
program Yeezy claims he's never voted
before in his life and registered for
the first time on Monday he still hasn't
registered with the Federal Election
Committee as a candidate but he's
already picked a running mate an obscure
preacher from Wyoming where Kanye has a
ranch what else have we learned Lots
Kanye says he had coronavirus in
February he thinks vaccines are the mark
of the beast he also came up with the
idea to run for president in the shower
at kris Jenner's house he says it hit me
to say you're going to run for president
and I started laughing hysterically I
have decided in 2020 to run for
president
he said he was high he admitted that he
had been smoking
one night yeah
[Music]